In recent years, Marvel movies have absolutely
dominated the box office and have brought
us some of the most memorable performances
of all time.
From Robert Downey Jr’s Ironman to Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool, some of the greatest actors
in the world are lining up to play heroes
from the Marvel comics.
While there is fantastic writing behind every
one of these characters, some of the most
amazing moments from these films happen when
the actors decide to go off script and just
let their impulses drive them.
For this video we are taking a look at some
of the best examples in our list of 10 Marvel
Superhero Movie Moments That Actors DID NOT
See Coming!
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit the subscribe
button to get more awesome Screen Rant content,
every single day!
The Avengers – RDJ’s Snacks
Robert Downey Jr has famously played badass
billionaire turned superhero Tony Stark since
2008 and it seems that his personality and
the character’s are starting to meld into
one.
During the filming of The Avengers RDJ hid
snacks around the set and as much as the crew
tried, they were unable to find them all.
The filmmakers decided to just go with it
and make snacking part of Tony Stark’s character.
During one scene where the gang is talking
about SHIELD Robert Downey Jr. starts randomly
offering blueberries to everyone and snacking
down on them himself.
This scene was of course not written into
the script at all and came as a total, but
admittedly pleasant, surprise to his
scene mates.
Age Of Ultron – Hawkeye Line
Until 2015’s Avengers Age Of Ultron, Hawkeye
was often ridiculed for being the most underused
and useless member of The Avengers.
The second team up movie gave Jeremy Renner’s
character more to do and the fans definitely
appreciated it.
On top of the action, Hawkeye and Quicksilver
begin to develop a fun love-hate relationship,
constantly challenging each other and at one
point, Quicksilver obnoxiously speeds away
from Hawkeye.
The archer then utters the hilarious line
“Nobody would know… ‘last I saw him,
Ultron was sitting on him!’”.
It was revealed later that this moment was
completely unscripted and something that Renner
came up with on the spot!
The Avengers – Shawarma Scene
2012’s The Avengers is still regarded as
one of the best superhero movies of all time
as it was brilliantly able to blend amazing
action and witty banter into one cohesive
super film.
The success of this franchise is in large
part due to the writers, but credit must also
be given to the cast who were able to find
chemistry with each other and even improvise
a bunch of the lines.
At the end of the movie, Robert Downey Jr.’s
Tony Stark delivers one of the best-unscripted
moments of the film when he suggests that
the crew head out for shawarma now that they
are done saving the world from Loki.
This improvised line was so good that it prompted
the now famous post credit scene of the whole
team chowing down together.
The Incredible Hulk Post Credit Scene
Marvel has had their shared universe all planned
out for years now but that doesn’t mean
that there wasn’t room for some fun improvisation
even at the beginning of the process.
At the end of 2008’s Incredible Hulk, Thaddeus
“Thunderbolt” Ross is drinking alone when
Tony Stark shows up.
A few jokes are made between the two, before
Tony Stark reveals that he is building a super
team (The Avengers).
The scene is great and feels very natural
so it made sense when the actors revealed
that the entire dialogue was improvised.
We are guessing that they were given some
guidelines (like make sure to mention The
Avengers), but the rest was left up to the
actors and the result was appreciated!
Thor – Odin Growls
Anthony Hopkins is one of the most respected
and talented actors working in Hollywood,
so it was pretty cool that he agreed to play
Asgardian ruler Odin in Thor.
Hopkins is known for completely throwing himself
into any role he does, and it turns out that
this one was no different.
In the scene where Odin is banishing Thor
and taking away his hammer, Anthony Hopkins
got so into character that when Hiddleston’s
Loki went to speak he let out a totally unscripted
but undeniably awesome growl.
When you watch the scene you can see the genuine
surprise on Thor and Loki’s faces, which
makes the moment all the more memorable.
Ant-Man – Three way conversations
Ant-Man is one of the funnier Marvel movies,
which makes sense when you consider that it’s
star, Paul Rudd, has mostly been a comedic
actor throughout his career.
As it turns out, Rudd wasn’t the only one
going off script during the shooting of the
heist superhero movie.
The cast revealed that most of the dialogue
in the scenes between Bobby Cannavale, Judy
Greer and Paul Rudd was completely improvised
and the actors were only given general directions
as to where the scenes needed to go.
The three characters are in a complicated
relationship, so the fact that they were able
to improvise together to create more genuine
dialogue is impressive.
Additionally, Michael Pena has also stated
that most of his scenes with Paul Rudd featured
improvised dialogue as well.
All of this makes you wonder if there ever
was a real script for Ant-Man or if they just
put a lot of trust in the talented cast.
The Amazing Spider-Man – Godzilla Joke
As bad as
the sequel was, The Amazing Spider-Man is
actually a pretty decent movie and it features
a lot of great performances.
One of the most underrated ones came from
Denis Leary who plays Captain Stacy in the
movie.
He is a very talented actor and one scene
has him make a pretty hilarious unscripted
joke that the cast did not see coming.
In the scene where Garfield’s Spider-man
is trying to worn Stacy and the rest of the
police force about a crazy giant lizard on
the loose and Leary quickly hits him back
with an improvised joke about Godzilla.
The joke took the rest of the cast by surprise
but they were able to not break character
and the great moment was able to make it into
the film in its purest form.
Guardians of The Galaxy – Rocket Raccoon
Chris Pratt has gotten a lot of credit for
the great improvised moments that he brought
to Guardians Of The Galaxy, but it turns out
that he wasn’t the only one bringing the
unscripted magic.
While Bradley Cooper voiced Rocket Raccoon,
it was actually director James Gunn’s brother,
Sean Gunn, who played the pre-CGI’d raccoon
during filming and it turns out he came up
with one of the best lines all on his own.
The line comes when the team is all gearing
up and agreeing to head off on their final
(and presumably fateful) mission.
Rocket Raccoon utters the line “We’re
all standing now.
Bunch of jackasses, standing in a circle,”
which turns out to have been a completely
unplanned moment courtesy of Sean Gunn.
Deadpool – ‘You Look Like’ Joke
Deadpool was one of the best movies of 2016
and it is now even being recognized with major
award nominations.
The script for the film was amazing but when
you put hilarious guys like Ryan Reynolds
and TJ Miller together, you are bound to end
up with some pretty great-unscripted moments.
The best-improvised moments from Deadpool
didn’t actually make it into the theatrical
release, but they can now be found online
and in the DVD special features.
In the scene where Reynolds is showing his
post operation face to TJ Miller, the two
actors were given the green light to improvise
and riff out as many zingers as they could.
One of the most hilarious moments that was
deemed to racy for the R rated flick came
when Miller said: ‘You look like a trucker
took a shit on your shoulders and then shaped
ears onto it’.
We understand why all these lines couldn’t
make the final cut, but they are awesome nonetheless.
Captain America: The First Avenger
There is no denying that Chris Evans got incredibly
jacked to play Steve Rogers in Captain America:
The First Avenger and we imagine that a lot
of people on set were taken by his incredible
physique.
Usually, that type of admiration stays out
of the actual production, but it turns out
that Hayley Atwell (who plays Peggy Carter
in the film) was unable to control herself.
In the scene were Christ Evans first emerges
as the jacked up super soldier, Atwell can’t
help but instinctively reach out and grab
his giant peck.
This scene is hilariously genuine as it turns
out that it was totally unplanned.
Evans reacted naturally and the moment was
able to stay in the film.
So there is our list of 10 Marvel Superhero
Movie Moments That Actors Did Not See Coming.
Which one of these moments is your favorite?
Are there any other unscripted Marvel moments
that you love?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!